pour refermer le journal je vous invite
à découvrir une œuvre méconnue de
léopéré méconnue et qui le serait resté
si un jeune admirateur du poète ne avait
pas fait un opéra le texte écrit en 1956
quitte donc l'ombre pour les lumières de
la scène à la grande joie de léopéré
complice est toujours jeune
écoutez si je devais retrouver la
jeunesse je serais mort depuis longtemps
moi je suis toujours jeune au jour je ne
serais plus jeune je m'en vais écoutez
bien écoutez
bien cette chemise
là cette chemise là
c'est de la
porésie pas de danger qu'il jette
l'éponge cet éternel jeune homme qui
fulmine contre tout en laissant derrière
lui les postillons de sa colère comme
une poussière d'étoile l'opéra du pauvre
cela fait 36 ans qu'il l'avait renfermé
dans ses cartons sur un coup de sang
encore cela s'appelait la nuit jusqu'à
ce qu'un garçon plus entêté qu'un autre
insiste pour la créer en version
scénique à Paris d'abord dans la plus
stricte indifférence aujourd'hui à
l'entour de la capitale comme un anneau
de lumière lu mentionnait bien sur le
disque que la mise en scène de l'opéra
du pauvre n'était pas envisagé ni au
théâtre ni au cinématographe et puis moi
je trouvais que c'était une œuvre
tellement riche qu'il fallait absolument
faire quelque chose pour la monté
justement c'était une sorte de défi un
petit peu et et puis je suis je suis
allé voir Léo Léo a bien accepté de de
me recevoir et puis on a discuté pendant
toute une soirée et il est parti dans sa
chambre d'hôtel il est allé me chercher
les bandes il m'a dit bon maintenant
c'est à toi je ne le connaissais pas je
me suis ditce qu' veux alors je lui ai
dit oui faites-le quoi
et il a fait ça c'est c'est
extraordinaire parce que il a fait ça
avec tant d'amour il a donné tout
l'amour à ses à ses acteurs à ses
actrices que c'est
devenu une œuvre enfin je sais pas moi
si on me donnera ça un jour je sais pas
parce que c'est encore moi moi je suis
de côté
toujours je suis l'anarchiste je suis
l'anarchie les gens ignorent ils savent
pas que c'est l'amour et la solitude
c'est
çaarchie
mais le drame c'est ce qui ce qui se
passe avec avec les données de la
chanson
maintenant le alors j'ai décidé de faire
quel chose je vais le faire je vais
faire un rap saz ce que c'est r Je faire
un r
voil et vous pouvez
toujours
[Musique]
l'affirere